there's more than 80 shops and that's
over 350,000 square feet based on five
floors altogether and really I don't
think they'll know sure who is where
exactly they'll have an idea of where in
the main groups are they entered the
mall it's thought in two groups one
through the doors at the main entrance
and they want through the parking
entrance that's at the back and then the
first reports to the police they thought
was just an armed robbery in the
supermarket but it became pretty obvious
that it was more than that up on the
second floor
you've got the planet media cinema
complex and at some point there was a
group barricaded in there it's thought
but again they said to have moved around
that's up by the cinema and apparently
the security forces of monitoring the
toilet blocks there on a corner of the
building but as I said five floors could
be anywhere the stairwells at each side
and then there are also lifts chefs
going through the centre so by now they
may have been able to get some of those
small secret cameras in that can have a
look around or have some listening
devices but I don't know how many of
those they have if they were able to get
them into such a complex situation so I
think it's it's something that that
favors the defenders rather than the
attack